but when Reagan is entertaining this
abolitionist fantasy getting rid of
nuclear weapons he says to him and the
notes show this week I yield 10 years
from now I'll be a very old man we can
come back here bury the last nuclear
weapon and have a party for the whole
world and I risky was seeing it as a
movie
hi I'm Nick Gillespie with reason TV and
today we're talking with the novelist
Thomas Malin who also teaches at George
Washington University his latest book is
finale a novel of the Reagan years Tom
thanks for talking to us he's family
this is a phenomenal book I i well if
you'd have put it all out there I was
just completely mesmerised describe the
setting and the scene of this book for
for us most of it takes place in late
nineteen eighty six which is probably
Ronald Reagan's low point as president
everything seems to be going wrong
there's this host of new social ills
that the administration doesn't seem
well equipped to deal with from aids to
crack to homelessness the Democrats are
about to take the Senate the reykjavík
summit which in the fullness of time
looks pretty good at the time was really
perceived to be a spell disaster and and
of course Iran Contra right is beginning
so and as you point out here and which
is documented really that Reagan's mind
was starting to slip a few gears right I
mean I'm not a clinician I don't know to
what extent and what was happening to
was that was compounding this remoteness
in him which was sort of constitutional
always part of him even Nancy for all
the vaunted closeness of that marriage
in her memoir she says there were places
within him that she never was able to go
to and that was part of his political
power really write that nobody could
really understand what he was made him
surprisingly malleable I mean Reagan
could be quite flexible politically even
though he was what mrs. Thatcher would
call a conviction politician not a
consensus one and I also think that it
gave a strange kind of energy to his
administration I mean in any
organization everybody wants to figure
out the boss wants to please the boss he
was so confusing to so many people that
I think they spent an enormous amount of
time and energy doing that and it might
have given a strange kind of boldness
and creativity to the it was a nobody
God is kind of he's present but he's
distant so you're desperate to please
him in your triangle yeah it's a stop
and he I mean he Reagan at moments I
think could be amazingly profound at
other moments I think he could be
unbelievably silly right and I knew
about two weeks into working on this
book that I was never going to be able
to make him a point-of-view character he
only for one scene does that happen I
will talk a little about that talk about
some of the other characters Pamela
Harriman Pamela Harriman is sort of the
Dowager Queen of the Democrats
government-in-exile she's the widow of a
virile Harriman at this point she's
gotten all of his money she had been
married to Winston Churchill son to
Randolph Churchill then she'd been
married to leland hayward the theatrical
producer she had had scads of affairs
with rich important men and johnny egg
Nellie le de Rothschild and her latest
incarnation is this political one and
she is a hostess in Georgetown and also
the head of a very powerful political
action committee which has a great deal
to do with the Democrats success in
recapturing the Senate that year so
she's there Nancy Reagan is there I I
think that portrait of Nancy is
sympathetic overall up but she's it's
complicated and she's bitching oh yeah
it's a tremendous hearted but she's kind
of a raw nerve and I don't think mrs.
Reagan enjoyed one hour of the time she
was in the White House I mean she wanted
to be there desperately but she was
constantly worried about her husband's
reputation short term long term then of
course Christopher Hitchens a journalist
who was very friendly to reason during
his all too brief life they were the
last significant political group in the
country to notice what was obvious to
the rest of us from the stuff just the
Royal Reagan is a fraud and now they
realized that he didn't mean a word he
really said that he he let down even his
dearest friends why is Hitchens in there
and what role does he play in this I
loved Christopher he was a good friend
of mine I didn't know him till later in
his life I first met him well into the
90s but this is Hitchens in his mid to
late 30s he still fairly new to the
States he's still trying to figure out
what his career dimensions are going to
be I have him migrating to Vanity Fair
and the slick magazines a little
bit earlier than he did while he's still
writing for a nation ill-gained laces
yeah like that and it's interesting
because even with Hitchens it's a very
sympathetic but there's a number of
warts in that portrait or were tensions
where you know both sexual as well as
financial he wants big money but he also
still is talking about how the
Sandinistas are you know somehow morally
superior when I was writing lines for
him you know if I thought really hard
and got lucky in maybe 15 minutes I
could come up with a line that was half
as funny as something he would have said
at the dinner table and you know with 15
seconds and then possibly the greatest
revelation here at least to this reader
of American fiction is your portrayal of
merv griffin talk a little bit i mean
and this is the type of book where all
sorts of interesting bizarre
off-the-wall characters come in and out
what is merv griffin's function he's um
he's mostly on the telephone in the book
he's only in a couple of scenes a
face-to-face but he was a pal of Nancy
Reagan's he was tremendously rich by
this point it just sold his company for
250 he created jeopardy and wheel of
fortune among other things and was about
to lose a shirt on a deal with Donald
Trump resorts it is not here in the book
that it was one reference to Leona
Helmsley uh you know she was the only
80s 80s plutocrat they've got cut but
Merv is one of Nancy Reagan's phone pals
Nancy Reagan probably spent as much time
on the phone while she was in the White
House's Lyndon Johnson did it was she
was never without it and Merv frequently
calls her up to say you know ooh great
speech and to buck her up a little bit
and to share Hollywood gossip with her
the protagonist of the novel if there is
when the invented characters someone
named Anders little who is at the
National Security Council so he is
somebody who is kind of weaving around
through Iran Contra he's at Reykjavik
talk a little bit about this character
and he's also on a journey of
self-discovery about a sexuality he is a
you know coming out at least to himself
well into his 30s after two brief
marriages and he also his true believer
pneus
in Regan's foreign policies being tested
by events but he had turned out he was a
loyal Democrat yeah and then he became
convinced of essentially what it became
known as a neocon that's right his
mentor is Jeanne Kirkpatrick when he's
very young he's up at the UN working
under her this shows him about five
years beyond that and and Anders is
conflicted even tormented he's a
compulsive runner and he is clearly very
vulnerable why is Anders conflicted over
sexuality and what does it mean in the
context of you know he's a hawk who
actually ultimately is vindicated in his
beliefs that a strong policy towards the
Soviet Union is right I've always been
betwixt in between politically I'm a gay
man myself I was sympathetic to rain
Reagan's foreign policy not sympathetic
to a lot of the rest of the things that
were going on I mean I was you know
dealing with my sick friends in New York
and we were waiting for a kind word from
Reagan about AIDS and so I hadn't
intended on dealing really with any of
that in the book but it was so much my
80s that it found its way into the book
I've always been fascinated though
partly because I've all my life been
challenged by my liberal friends which
is most of them how the hell can you a
gay man throw your lot in so often you
know with these Republican characters
whereas on social issues I'm probably
not libertarian in the room since you
guys have of the term but the way an
ordinary political commentator might
have of that term and you know so does
that mean that you're in favor of gay
marriage but not the gold standard I I
think it means I don't make gay marriage
the gold standard of okay or the litmus
test for know who I vote for I mean I
was i'm in favor of gay marriage but i
would I wish it had not been the Supreme
Court they decided it but I am
interested in you know there was a
tremendous gay subtext to around
this fellow spits channel who died quite
young and a lot of the people who were
involved an earlier novel Michael fellow
travelers were dealt to some extent with
the gay subtext of the McCarthy period
and it's fascinating them because
McCarthy himself yeah and I think you've
written about this or talked about it in
interviews where he was a libidinous
Boozer who yeah grabby you know when we
got drunk he was surrounded by gay men
right it's not clear what's going on
with all of that but then somebody like
Jagger Hoover very consciously linked
being gay with being a communist or
being subversive and there's all of
these interesting moments of doubling
you know if you live a double life can
you really be American etc so one of the
epigraphs in this novel fellow travelers
mine has daniel patrick moynihan squat
in the age of security clearances to be
irish catholic was prima facie evidence
of anti-communism Harvard men were to be
checked for two men would do the
checking you know growing up Irish
Catholic around New York at the apex of
Catholic influence in America the New
York archdiocese the Kennedy presidency
whatever I mean we considered ourselves
I think super Americans in a way because
we were militantly anti-communist we
were not squish aliso like liberal
Protestants and but how that could
combine with or even survive proximity
to something like one's own
homosexuality clearly was something that
interested me and are we past that point
have we kind of gotten out of that
historical unit our patch I don't think
so I like to think that the supreme
court decision sort of settled the
matter so that we could get on to more
interesting things I mean I think that
one of the things was even in the 1980s
I never felt as oppressed as an ordinary
heterosexual living in Poland and I was
very cognizant of that I had my troubles
and there were certain things I wished
were otherwise but Anders even says this
in the book i'm willing to stand in line
for my freedom
and but I think in the course of the
fight for gay marriage in particular
that led up to the Supreme Court
decision people have gotten so Doug and
that i find the reaction to any
expression of conservatism say on my
part to be even more since aureus maybe
than it ever was talk a little bit about
your conservativism then because this is
something in the libertarian movement
you know small while their voice there's
always been a lot of gay people gay and
lesbian people who you know felt okay
well look I'm anti-communist I'm anti
government because the government you
know its government cops and and
government agents who are like rousting
me and yet I couldn't you know like I
can't feel comfortable being with
liberals because they you know they want
to empower the state even more is that
complicated for or why did the why did
the public gay identity seem to go so
far to the left in the short run the
left was pushing particular portions of
the gay rights agenda and so it was
understandable in the long term I'm not
sure that reliance on the state you know
is so good for anybody's freedom and it
is true in the 80s I mean the way that
Republicans and many Democrats actually
but it became more of a kind of defining
issue of the Republicans people like
Jesse Helms I mean we're virulent Lee
homophobic and anti-gay and you know
that I don't recall hearing anybody on
the in the Democratic Party talking
about aids as divine retribution for
right right you know a bad lifestyle if
the homosexuals and IV drug abusers
would stop their abnormal practices this
date there would never be another new
case of AIDS in the United States and I
mean you have the very conflicted Terry
Dolan here who's the head of the very
conservative pack who is himself gay and
dies of AIDS late in 86 and there so
there was that you know stratum
in the Republican Party but I think that
it you know it was natural enough for
gay activists to gravitate toward the
liberal wing of the Democratic Party and
yet you know I remember conversations in
the 80s that I would have where I would
have to listen to gay friends be
rhapsodic about Fidel Castro and you
know the level of medical care in Cuba
and I I give Andrew says one of these
lines to where he says some it's a
variant of what I used to tell people
will you know you know dressed up like
Carmen Miranda on Friday night you're
going to be cutting sugar cane on Monday
and where you can share a prison cell
with your lover right yeah and I you
know and to me the only way to operate
was to try to operate according to the
largest possible political issues and
try to operate in a way that would
maximize freedom for everyone and then
you know as these is a boring from
within to push on the people that you
were aligning ourselves with do you feel
like I mean do you consider yourself a
Republican then and in terms of partisan
I it's funny I was actually in the
George W Bush administration for a while
I was at the neh which is not an
organization libertarian second life i
missed the deputy chair for a couple of
years and i remember i was first on the
National Council and I remember the call
from the White House personnel office
which sounds funny to begin with and I
said well the two things you got to know
that mean I said I can only serve as a
an openly gay man and that was fine
that's no problem this was the
compassionate conservative era and then
the second one as I said you know I'm
not a registered Republican I said I
voted for the president but I'm not
ready I eventually did register as a
Republican which is probably a flawed my
moral character but i thought you know i
take the king ceiling I am the Kings
mana but after the 1980s I I could never
imagine again voting for a Democrat for
president because I do think that the
Democratic Party by and large not
everyone in it but by and large the
Democratic Party walked away from the
cold war which was the biggest issue of
my life
time you you paint a picture of you know
it seems like the cold war is about to
be lost the Americans are Ethel is that
obviously Reykjavik turns out to be a
breakthrough and Reagan is revealed as a
genius kind of negotiator I'll talk a
little bit about that I mean your work
is the fuse with the kind of
appreciation for the ironies of history
talk about about how that plays out in
that in the grand scheme of this book I
think Reagan knocked Gorbachev
off-balance a lot at Reykjavik for the
same reasons he knocked his staff of
balance a lot Gorbachev couldn't figure
him out and when Reagan is really
proposing the Gorbachev that they think
about getting rid of nuclear weapons
entirely something he walks away from
because he won't give up SDI bro dharwar
Strategic Defense Initiative which at
the time was widely criticized even by
people it was widely disbelieve
different by people within Reagan's
administration yeah this was some kind
of weird fantasy that thing that the old
right hat let me share with you a vision
of the future which offers hope it is
that we embarked on a program to counter
the awesome Soviet missile threat with
measures that are defensive here an
artist projection of the president's
vision
particle beam weapons with pulsing
raised join the attack but the Soviets
believed in it enough to think that if
they keep researching this we've got a
researcher too and that was I think what
ultimately was the boon of Reykjavik
that they went home and sort of spent
themselves into this death spiral but
when Reagan's entertaining this
abolitionist fantasy getting rid of
nuclear weapons he says to him and the
notes show this meka heel I mean that
the note-taker makes a point of showing
you used his first name 10 years from
now I'll be a very old man we can come
back here bury the last nuclear weapon
and have a party for the whole world and
he goes on with this and he says you'll
say Ron is that you and I'll say Nick I
yield it's good to see you and I really
was seeing it as a movie so his
theatrical experience I think in many
ways served him quite well but I do not
believe the cold war would have ended
certainly not when it did had Reagan not
pushed on the Soviet Union for the whole
age so and very much in the book is the
idea that he if he whether or not the
communism was beset by internal strife
or internal contradictions it was he
helped spend make it spend itself in
right meat sauce I can't stand what I
call the strobe Talbott view of the Cold
War which is while Reagan was provoking
the Soviet Union in the early 80s oh we
have to learn to coexist the Soviet
Union is too big to antagonize like this
and then the minute the Soviet Union
collapsed see they were too weak to have
worried about all along I don't think
you can have it both ways like that when
Reagan was asked his view of the Cold
War by the man who became his national
security advisor while he was still just
the Governor of California vet running
for president and Richard Allen asked
him well what's your view of the Cold
War governor and Reagan looks and he
goes we win they lose and to me that was
moral clarity and I saw in the 80s the
Democratic Party walking away from the
policies of Truman and kennedy and
johnson which had been aggressive toward
sure communism
even an even Kennedy I mean Kennedy beat
Nixon by painting Nixon is soft on right
commits the missile gap yeah and even if
their policy was only containment but
you know by the mid 70s the Soviet Union
was on the march everywhere in Africa
Central America whatever where'd where
do you end up in on the question of
Nixon because he obviously on a certain
level you know he was the great
instigator of date aunt and it seemed
that he was more than happy to live in a
world with the Soviet Union in many ways
he wanted it to always always exist
Nixon was incredibly light Margaret
Thatcher was incredibly opposed to this
notion of abolition I mean he thought if
we draw down nuclear weapons 20 the
Soviets are going to roll over Europe
with conventional forces but I don't I
think in a way Reagan because he was
simpler than Nixon in some ways more
sentimental than Nixon whatever he
allowed himself to imagine a world
without the Soviet Union which Nixon's
mind much more brilliant than Reagan's
couldn't quite bring him for you know I
died I was too young to really catch us
on the first run but when you go back
and you look I'm not even sure if Nixon
was on the Merv Griffin Show or the Mike
Douglas show or Dinah Shore but he is an
incredible conversationalist even
comedians who refer to richard nixon as
a loser Churchill franklin roosevelt
Mikan all lost elections before they won
the big Nixon was the politician who
dominated my lifetime in many ways much
more than Reagan even though Reagan is
sort of the climax of the Cold War I
mean my first real political memory is
the 1960 election I went to fourth grade
every day wearing a Nixon button some
Catholic where we was this was on Long
Island and we were you know all Irish
Catholics but my father and all of the
other men on the street the vast
majority of them were for Nixon not
Kennedy they looked at Kennedy and they
saw somebody who gon Harvard they looked
at Nixon and he looked like what they
were doing that is certainly mother I
Catholic that I come out yeah there's a
small minority of people who are Kennedy
haters precisely because he was the
better version of themselves right and
he was a Nixon is you know he was the
president for my entire college career
and in he the complexities of him the
moral failures of him I don't know what
it says about my character but I never
had any difficulty I never felt any
difficulty writing from inside out with
Nixon Nixon was and is in this book to a
point okay does any of this matter
anymore what what does it mean now that
we have Putin who is a you know a
diminutive version of grey of the Soviet
Union or Gorbachev Oh Brezhnev in the
Middle East we have a feckless American
president his foreign policy is terrible
and probably almost as bad as the one
before that it was a Republican great
what what what is the pressing relevance
of this for today in America in a way
the world that was bequeathed two recent
Presidents by reagan and bush they were
given a splendid gift none of them have
cherished it properly is it is this the
one more kind of nail and the baby
boomers coffin that really they were
given everything and they just rocked it
up you know I think the first George
Bush was a very good manager of the end
of the Cold War but I think it Clinton
for all his personal recklessness was a
very cautious president in foreign
policy he did not really consolidate the
Pax Americana that he inherited and
currently I mean I think things are
terrible I mean Putin i think is
essentially a fascist and obama does not
have a clue as to how to deal with him
the Russians are running rampant in the
Middle East right now they bolide
themselves should we care I mean this is
the libertarian speaking you know yeah
it's not it wasn't our fight to begin
with and why would you know whose
children should go over there too
i right now for people who will you know
in a couple of generations be sending
terrorists over here well they're going
to be sending more of them and sooner I
think if we don't do that I mean you
know if they're not fought over there
they're going to be fought over here and
I I can't stand uh the president's
relish the current president well as for
a small American footprint this is very
unliberated ya know what I mean what I
mean is that because you cannot conceive
of a world in which America is not the
top dog I mean where we you know in
every other aspects of our lives we
understand that you know what Americans
don't have to be number one in steel
manufacturing for us to be very good we
don't have to win every Olympic of that
we don't have to play chess anymore
thank God that the Cold War we don't
have to pretend to like chess you know
why do we have to be everywhere in the
world well that goes back to that
Catholic childhood where you know you
were inculcated with the sense that you
were the Super Americans and the belief
in America was second only to belief in
God and they went together if you
watched Bishop Sheen every week on
television you know the way I did and I
I do believe that and I mean it you know
the famous Barbara Jordan quote about
the Constitution I mean do you know I
mean I always would sort of say the same
thing sentimental as it sounds about
America my faith is hold it is total it
is complete no one else is going to do
it and and I do know that in the largest
certainly in the largest political
theoretical sense that is at odds with a
libertarian view but is it also does it
lead the u.s. into situations where
we're so morally compromised that we
cannot really lead the world you know
because ultimately what you're talking
about really is a moral vision as much
as a kind of geopolitical one yeah it's
like if the United States is torturing
people if the United States is you know
dropping bombs indiscriminately on
hospitals in the name of liberating the
people i mean this goes back to wherein
a weird phase where Aramis destroying
countries in order to preserve them
which are conspire of Vietnam conundrum
you know I mean is that vision in a
post-cold war world because there is no
existential threat to the United States
of you know radical Islam is a pimple
it's a it's herpes it's not aids you
know I mean it almost seems like you're
creating a monster that we have to slay
and the way you're awfully soft on
religion for a libertarian I i I'd
footage i put radical islam much higher
up with the list I think it was fiercely
small after shortly a 911 he said he
doesn't fear the Islamist because they
can fly planes into buildings but they
can't build the planes themselves and
that you know there's a lot of truth to
that that you know there it's a
defensive it's a suicide cult it's not
it's not it's not part of the West like
communism one yeah we were morally
compromised winning the Cold War I mean
look at Iran Contra yeah i mean the
Contras contained some of the shadiest
and most thuggish people it is also the
fact that Reagan reneged on one of his
main promises that we would never trade
you know we wouldn't trade weapons for
hostages right and that he also believed
in the Constitution while subverting and
every opportunity it was a very ill
chosen dirty skirmish but I think one of
the reasons Reagan and comes out alright
in history is that people look at the
Contra part of Iran Contra and say well
dirty as it was and foolish as it was it
was one battle in this much larger war
which ultimately did have a moral
content to it and which he ultimately
was on the winning side let's talk a
little bit more broadly about literature
or contemporary novel writing you know
you're you're one of the only serious
novelist who not only lives in DC but
actually writes about politics and power
and what what has happened I mean you
you were a protege or you had a fond
relationship with Mary McCarthy
you know a novelist and memoirist and
political commentator from an earlier
period who was very outspoken and her
generally left wing news I cannot
understand how the public could identify
itself with Nixon I simply cannot
understand it I could understand their
identifying with our LBJ with Truman
even with Eisenhower and some sort of
son or daughter relations that I know I
cannot see how this other people looking
at that man on television could identify
themselves with it there were writers
like Noren mailer and gore Vidal and
Saul Bellow you know all over the
political spectrum these guys traded and
women traded in big ideas about the
politics of the day today that seems to
be almost completely vacant yes from
serious fiction why do you think these
big big figures most of them born in the
teens in the 20s I you know Mary was
mitigated I realized i was also
catholics others i guess well there's
that too but you know she had that
Jewish grandmother the Hitchens streak
in her you know Mary politically her
original identity for all that she's so
identified with the left going to
Vietnam and all of the rest she was an
anti Stalinist right not easy to be in
1930s 1940s literary New York you know
she had a flirtation with trotskyism and
her politics sort of were accidental but
the anti-communist aspect of them which
is so much part of her early life that
was in many ways what appealed to me
about her but in terms of just political
zeal and mixing it up yes I find that
they they were infinitely more
interesting than the novelist's of my
generation novelist of my generation
won't even take one another on in book
reviews I mean the writers you're
mentioning they were constantly feuding
with one another attacking one another
coming to one another's aid whatever in
the book reviews that exists today the
editor will call up one literary novel
is asking him to review another
so we'll send me the book and if I like
it I'll do the review because nobody
wants to antagonize somebody they're
going to meet at a Writers Conference
things like that and there is such a
generic default politics I mean 95 loose
innate that you know what I percent of
the writers I know are liberal democrats
and do they even care about politics
really or is it kind of it I think they
do it so do that they put on yeah it's
truly but they don't really are I think
they think they do but they they're not
much engaged by it they they sign the
petitions that everybody else is signing
so that there's an infinite lack of
surprise and seeing their names there I
don't think that they're that much
engaged there's a kind of lockstep about
it and I don't think it's very fresh are
they all thinking the same because they
all come out of the same basic
socio-economic Mel you or is it that
they're confessional and we're in an age
of kind of personal introspection and
memoir I think of someone like Jonathan
Franzen who's major political commitment
seemed to be preserving habitats for
wild animals in Central Park of New York
where he recently said that he was
thinking about adopting an Iraqi child
in order to learn something about the
third world I mean these are you know
he's not a stupid person hears a gifted
writer but these are that's you know
these are idiotic statements you know
what what where is that coming from I
don't think it's so much that they all
come out of the same world as that they
all wind up in the same work they all
teach they're all tenured novelists you
know they ride the same circuit the
lives are very similar in past
generations novelists were not tied to
the Academy the way they are now they
had much more disparate backgrounds you
know you used to pick up book flaps and
say somebody has worked as a lobster
moon and you know the door yeah that
doesn't happen much anymore and among
most of the writers I know their
politics they're a token of good
breeding they're a token there I
potentially losing the long I
accent yeah yeah it's the exact I kinda
centrist maybe a little edge towards the
left on the cage it shows you're fit for
polite society and you know I was at a
dinner party on Saturday night with some
writers a nice that at one point the
mildest thing against the incumbent of
the White House and you can't even say
his name he's that man what that man in
the White House uh and all I said was
that you know we were on Reagan and I
said well you know Reagan he raised the
age level for presents which is why
we're going to have this alte Cocker
primary among the Democrats but i said i
think obama did what Obama did of course
was lower the experience loved ones why
we have all these first term senators
running for president you could see the
look like oh please don't go there Tom
we we like you're a nice guy but please
don't go beyond the pale and it was as
if I you know had picked up her bread
roll and might have thrown it and and so
what did i do as a member of the same
polite society there and I just assisted
and we moved on to other topics who were
the novelist that you know that excites
you today several years ago the New York
Times Book Review asked a bunch of us to
name what we thought was the best novel
of the last 25 years and at that point I
said it was underworld and it was don
delillo i think is tremendous I said
somebody like Don DeLillo a great
example of his entire work led up to
nine eleven putting in I think it might
have been running dogs he actually had
figures look at the world trade centers
and fantasize about destroying okay we
can never underestimate the willingness
of the state to act out its own massive
fantasies what about the individual and
then when a massive act an unbelievable
novelistic act of violence happens he
kind of takes a break for a couple years
than the hands back with a minor book I
think the only man which is not even
real I mean it starts in New York and
then it dissipates into a
kind of global poker torna yeah I mean
it seems to me that he's some he almost
like one of his own characters he is
presented as a world historic
opportunity and blows it I remember
reading underworld and writing about it
and thinking how am I going to live
outside this Manichean world that I grew
up in which I I think you know that
novel embodies very brilliantly and I
think he may be not even entirely
consciously he may be struggling with
that you know as well I love reading
Martin Amis and in many ways you must
love letters anti-communist books in
particular image yeah he grew a little
into that he sort of brewing to his
father's politics to someone hopefully
modesty anti-semitism is well maybe not
the massager yeah but yeah I don't think
that my generation of novelists is
producing the books that were produced
after the Second World War by writers
who were born typically between the two
world wars III don't think is that
because the novel I mean it in a way the
novel as a cultural form is kind of lost
its gas I mean it's running oh they're
not and I mean that partly get to sound
like a Marxist if you know feudalism
gave us the epic poem or the epic and
romance you know the the Industrial
Revolution gave us the novel and now
we're moving into is it is it or is it
this is it film is it another form that
has captured the complexity of society I
think that there is such a premium on
documenting things every person holding
up his iphone a hundred times a day to
take a picture of something everybody
posting his thoughts on the internet
whatever I think the whole notion of
fictionalizing anything begins to seem
precious and trivial to a lot of people
they don't see fictions expansive
possibilities anymore I think that's why
among many young writers memoir has
taken over from
fiction and you know first books that
would typically have been
autobiographical novels are now
published as memoirs the memoirs contain
every bit as much fiction as those
autobiographical novel series just yes
contain but there is this free soul that
people get from the notion of reality i
mean the in an extreme you know people
who started out as fiction writers David
shields a little younger than I am you
know they've just really walked away
from it because it just doesn't seem to
be it doesn't seem to challenge them it
doesn't seem to fulfill them anymore Tom
Wolfe who kind of navigated a fairly
spectacular turn from creative
nonfiction or New Journalism whatever we
want to call it to fiction and I think
as most successful fiction work was his
first novel bonfire of the vanities but
he talked a lot about how in the early
sixties Philip Roth wrote an essay where
he said you know the problem for
novelists is that we can't keep up with
the bizarreness and the absurdity yeah
contemporary life and and Wolf said you
know this was great novelists walked
away from that and they started writing
about themselves writing about writing
medication sir fiction whatever he
wanted to call it and so journalists
moved in to document thing who's in
creative ways and that explains you know
the electric kool-aid acid test and
Hells Angels isn't cold in cold blood
non fiction novels the executioner song
and then wolf came back when he wrote
the bonfire of the vanities in the 80s
and said you know what we need the novel
not of manners but of society right
thick-cut of society such as you
provided herein ali and your other works
will that be enough do you think to kind
of revive the novel or regain interested
it is Margaret Thatcher Mike addressed
the question no a single word I don't I
mean a the passage he made to go from
nonfiction to fiction was a quite
solitary journey and I think he
infuriated a lot of established novels
Bo especially because the first book was
this enormous bestseller that
is also rapturously received I don't see
right now any signs that the trend is
going to be reversed although with very
young writers I find the the students I
teach writing to whatever on they are a
surprising number of them are really
interested in fantasy writing you know
the most fictional kind of fiction and
and there i mean it's fiction that is
built upon building and imagining world
and video games and lots of dungeons and
lots of fair maidens and lots of
vampires and you know this leaves me
cold and I mean when they submit managed
to because I have to tell them like I
got nothing I got nothing to bring to
this you know we're gonna have to set
you up with somebody else but they
certainly the notion of you know the
Great American Novel that's going to
capture the spirit of the age I think
that that's been gone for a long maybe
the great american novel is busily
busily being written in shanghai uh it's
really possible or pirated yeah it's run
every right well we'll leave it there
the novel is finale a novel of the
Reagan years by Thomas mal and I can't
recommend it enough time thanks for
talking thank you very much for reason
TV I'm necklace tea